uh thanks yes Rex first of all welcome
to the show I will ask you about the
games and these tournaments in just a
second but I first want to touch on the
anniversary that the club just
celebrated 15 years of the St Louis
chess club tell us about your experience
with chess
oh you don't want to know that it's just
horrible stories
yeah but 15 years is remarkable it's
really a testimony to the tremendous
staff we have and people like you and
and all of our commentators including
the great Yasser
is in the room next to us yeah he's
listening that's why don't praise him
too much I'm watching I'm watching Rex I
have to say something nice you know I I
spent an hour preparing that remark
but it's just a tremendous testimony to
the staff that we've had over the years
they've done such a great job and I
don't even know what I'm doing here
these people are so Good by themselves
uh but it was great it was great to see
several hundred kids there from all over
the city coming in what a wonderful
celebration for everybody absolutely and
we can see that on the screen you we
even had ice cream
we had a lot of fun doc chess ice cream
and that's one of the things that the
Saint Louis chess club focuses taking
young kids from a young age taking them
all the way to the U.S championships
right and this tournament is definitely
aimed at that as well we've grown and
nurtured some of the best talent in the
country how proud that are you oh see
Alice Lee here only 13 years of age and
it's just amazing incredible how far is
she gonna go and and how quickly nobody
knows but right now it's uh it looks
pretty good pretty great yeah yeah and
we had Malik set he mentioned that he
received that invitation like a week
before Oh yes we were talking about that
last night and he comes in thinking well
you know might not be that great it was
terrible last year and look at him the
wind's going away you know absolutely
also no losses whatsoever is this what
you have to do in this Championship oh
boy I'll tell you it's tough to win you
know it's hard to win a single game let
alone what these people do to win an
event that's pretty impressive for all
of them Rex I have to ask you we need to
put some pressure on Yasser we need to
get him to play the U.S seniors
championship
I think he's too old
thank you Rex thank you
thank you is that Yasser right here
thank you he's saying thank you you're
being nice to him right now actually
guys any questions
big time any questions first of all
thank you so much for what you've been
doing which has I love being in St Louis
as a player playing the US Championship
as a coaching chess camps commentator
journalist everything is fantastic I
really love being in Saint Louis it is
the chess Capital but my question is you
know you've done so many things in Saint
Louis again U.S Championship you know
sing feel Gap you have a Casper over
here Magnus Carlos and you have the top
women in the Karens cup just what is the
plan for the next 15 years what how do
you want to Trump that
trumpet I don't I didn't know that he
was going to be involved
well you know we still haven't had a
world championship here we need a world
championship with a St Louis Contender
okay at least with an American Contender
I'd settle for St Louis Contender those
are big plans yes sir well first of all
Rex just to correct you you are on the
appeals Committee of the 1886 World
Championship here in St Louis as you I
remember I don't remember it well so
is already hosted a world championship
if you want to host another one that's
fine but I wanted to say to you that
thank you very much I had a really
really nice time last week we had gone
to the muni for the musical chess you
brought Chess the musical to St Louis
tell us about that how did that happen
well you know they just approached us
and they said would you like to bring
Chess the musical here and I thought
about that should I Say Yes Should I Say
No I said well I'll say yes so that's
how it happened that's how it was a
wonderful thing and and we've been
talking about it and uh well what can
you say about that Performance Group at
the muni they are just out of this world
wasn't that magnificent it was fantastic
all the time yep wow and you guys got to
meet them right yeah we went backstage
and met the performers and there was a
lot of children in the musical as well
they all got chess sets uh from the
chess club they were all super happy
with their swag so Rex once again thank
you for all your support and everything
that you and Jeannie have done for chess
it's it's been terrific in the next 15
years you're way too kind no not at all
and by the way
I'm a little upset with you because we
played ducky chess and I'm telling you
you were a ringer you you made me play
much better than I I was a formidable
challenge what the hell I spent three
days preparing
[Laughter]
we're so proud of your ex because that
chess is the greatest variant I'm
telling you Rex thank you thank you very
much for sure absolutely thank you thank
you wow no that that